Elon Musk telling the employees at
Twitter we're going to ask you to work
harder than you've ever worked in your
life this is a place Twitter is now a
company where people can go if they want
to be in the top naught Point not not
one percent of hard-working programmers
and software developers on the planet
and there was everybody was up in arms
this is unbelievable we're going back to
this old version of capitalism where the
worker is being abused and used and
thrown away what they didn't account for
is that there is a non-insignificant
cohort of people for whom that's their
dream people who want to be able to get
up on a morning having gone to bed four
hours before and can contribute to some
sort of progress that they think this
this is what I'm here for yep